how's life it's great man's been busy
yesterday and today okay it's going are
you finally 21 yet are you 20 yeah I'm
22 now
22 news yeah 22 well that you're gonna
start getting gray in your beard right
no in just well certainly you know what
goes on in Pittsburgh from time to time
that'll make you lose your hair too you
know yeah like the Kardashians it's
tough to keep up with the Pittsburgh
Steelers yeah but it's just watching you
play you play with a certain you know
shall we say enjoyment that comes
through where did that come from juju I
don't know actually believe that know my
number one rule in life is always have
fun and I've been doing it since I was a
kid obviously I love this game and you
know everything that comes with it it's
just a plus but you out there and play
football that I've been doing just as I
was four years old it's just what I love
doing and just enjoy Madonna don't love
to have fun and you still riding your
bike you still doing that or that that's
gone no not actually I like five bikes
so you know I ride during the summer
not now I'm it's like a blizzard in
Pittsburgh right now okay yeah
do you don't ride in the cold weather
now not to say I mean you're from
Southern California are you not yep okay
you went to USC how do you handle the
cold she's got to embrace it I think
over time I parry you know you get used
to it you playing it you practice in it
and then incoming and ages it's to our
advantage
okay so before we we get to a Gatorade
here I I mean everybody's talking to you
about Antonia Brown I'm sure yeah for
sure so that's my way of getting right
into it
well I mean you know we just got to cut
straight to the chase we could ask I
could ask you about would you like me to
ask about the area's Heyward Bay instead
I mean I don't know if that's got the
same sort of juice to it
Ryan Switzer when the last time you
spoke when was the last time you spoke
to him Tonio Brown was last time I was a
season any season I didn't after that
it's been a vacation and I just don't
bother him okay but do you talk to other
teammates though oh yeah yeah I mean I
was just the Pro Bowl with some other
guys like TJ wah you know camera Hayward
and then
you know Pouncy all those guys you know
I talked to Ryan Spitzer if you're
wondering yeah I'm wondering if you
talked to Ryan Swiss yeah yeah we talked
about bass aw okay so do you have you
spoken to your coach Mike Tomlin he'd be
spoken I spoke to him two two days ago
okay big man have you spoken to big man
I talked I spoke to Ben what's he up to
chilling in Pittsburgh that's it yeah
okay
so I I think you know where I'm driving
at here is is Antonio is instagramming
out pictures of himself we're in San
Francisco 49er uniform and and Art
Rooney is saying essentially that he
thinks it's not fixable in many ways do
you think that it is fixable with
Antonio Brown I think it's fixable I
think over a time a period I'm just
gonna hear I mean at the end of the day
you know I think Antonio Brown you know
he bleeds black and go he's the slowest
for life you can see his first career
hit number she's put up it's been
amazing the chemistry here has what Ben
is unbelievable because the numbers he's
put up and I think he stays I don't
think he goes anywhere else honestly we
have all the pieces to the puzzle and if
we all stay and just play together for
one go we win a Super Bowl do you think
your emergence in any way has gotten him
a little jealous
I think the competitiveness I don't I
don't think it's more jealousy just you
know want to be better
you know I you know me being on the team
makes him better and he makes me better
and we just compete what about you being
voted MVP of the team what did that mean
to you
I mean means the world you know honestly
to hire your peers pick your MVP not
anything I was gonna you know in it
there's so many great players on a team
that couldn't want it and to have the
opportunity to go and receive this award
it's been it's been crazy but I mean in
in you being asked about the state of
the Pittsburgh Steelers do you think
this the whatever was going on whatever
did go on whatever what we assumed was
going on did in fact lead to you not
going on into the playoffs when it's all
said and done yeah I mean our season you
know we started off with the situation
with al Bell and then you know the
situation you know a be at the end of
the day there was
during the season that you know James
Connor did amazing he had over a
thousand yards you know that was TDs and
he field that's that that roll me a B
had a hundred catches Plus had a
thousand yards you know there's just
games that we just fell short you know
whether it's a you know a missed field
goal or you know we do interception in
the end zone there's a lot of reasons
why we fell short towards the end you
know the fumble against the Saints that
you know I cause there's a lot of
reasons why and at the end we have to
depend on another team you know to make
the toss
but we're all you know watching in the
state and we shouldn't be doing it okay
so you're here courtesy of Gatorade and
Gatorade zero is that what we have right
here in the desk right here there you go
that's yours is this mine yeah can I can
I use it to hydrate you know I'm running
this weekend we're okay 40-yard dash no
you know I do that every year juju I'm
doing it against Usain Bolt this week oh
you have any tips let me suggest an
other than obviously hydrating with
Gatorade Zero prior and after honesty I
will just say use Gatorade zero you know
for your workouts and I'm pretty sure
your beef acity were last year see
that's why you're you're voted MVP
you're a good guy you know you make your
teammates better and I consider myself a
teammate of yours right here before I
let you go sir because I know that
you're heading to radio row as well who
do you think wins this Super Bowl you've
beaten the Patriots yourself and
obviously you know the Rams having
watched them I assumed throughout the
playoffs what do you got for me right so
I got the Rams winning I'm taking the
Rams I'm Ellie a native okay I want to
see this franchise win a Super Bowl and
you know it's amazing because I got it
Aaron Donna's MVP you know four to five
sacks I'm saying okay and uh
32:27 let's just say give me a score cuz
you're thinking this don't think so
thirty twenty seven Rams and Donald's
yeah and I got their take they're
winning the photo for though that is as
specific as it possibly gets let me
write that Donovan's awesome round of
applause for juju Smiths Shuster here
sighs until the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience